IT PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T VOTE FOR
JOE ARE SUFFERING THE MOST.
THIS CE ZERO OF, NED, GREAT TO
SEE YOU TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
SADLY I THINK WE HAVE TO ASK TH
QUESTION IS PROBABLY ON THE TOP
OF EVERYONE'S MIND.
IT'S BAD, BUT HOW BAD CAN IT GET
?
>> I DON'T THINK WE'RE ANYWHERE
NEAR THE BOTTOM.
WHEN YOU HEAR BIDEN IN THE
SPENDING MORE REGULATION, I MEAN
, THESE WILL BE JET FUEL ON
INFLATION AND CONTINUE TO TAKE
THE ECONOMY.
SO, WHEN PEOPLE HEAR THESE AS
THE SOLUTIONS, THIS IS WHY HE'S
GOING DOWN WITH HISPANICS,
INDEPENDENTS I WOULD ALSO POINT
OUT THAT HE'S AT 57 PERCENT
APPROVAL IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY
IN TO GIVE PEOPLE PERSPECTIVE,
RIGHT BEFORE DEMOCRATS GOT
COMPLETELY SHELLACKED IN THE
2010 MIDTERMS, OBAMA WAS STILL
OVER 90 PERCENT WITH THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
THIS THING IS ABSOLUTELY
TRENDING AND THE WRONG DIRECTION
.
THE THING I WANT TO POINT OUT T
PEOPLE IS THIS, THESE ARE NOT
BUGS, THESE ARE FEATURES OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, THE
OUTRAGEOUS GOVERNMENT SPENDING,
THE TERRIBLE ENERGY POLICY, ALL
OF THESE THINGS ARE ABSOLUTELY
INTENTIONAL.
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY'RE GOING TO
WAKE UP SOMEDAY AND SAY WE MADE
MISTAKES WE'RE GOING TO SOLVE I
THESE ARE INTENTIONAL THEY'RE
DOING IT IN SUCH A WAY TO COMPE
CERTAIN BEHAVIOR.
WHEN I HEAR PEOPLE TALKING ABOU
$6 FOR A GALLON OF GAS, I KNOW
MANY ON THE LEFT WOULD PREFER
$10 TO A GALLON OF GAS TO COMPE
PEOPLE START START USING
RENEWABLES TO FORCE THAT
BEHAVIOR ON PEOPLE.
THEY DO NOT CARE ABOUT THE
PRIORITIES OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THEY DO NOT CARE ABOUT
ANYTHING THAT WILL ACTUALLY
BENEFIT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
BECAUSE QUITE FRANKLY IN THEIR
ARROGANCE, THEY DON'T THINK THE
DIRTY LITTLE PEASANTS KNOW WHAT
IS BEST FOR THEM.
YOU WOULD THINK THEY DO CARE
ABOUT WINNING.
ALL OF THIS THEY ARE PUTTING IN
PLACE AND WHAT YOU SUGGESTED IS
THAT IT'S A FEATURE, NOT A BUG
WOULD SEEM TO GET IN THE WAY OF
WINNING AN ELECTION, THE
MIDTERMS ARE IN 2024, WHERE IS
THEIR SENSE OF VICTORY?
WHERE IS THEIR SENSE OF A
SELF-CORRECTING MECHANISM?
>> I THINK THEY ARE SO FAR GONE.
THEY'RE STUCK BETWEEN A ROCK AN
A HARD PLACE IN WHICH THE FAR
LEFT IS REALLY TAKEN OVER THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THEY CAN'T
PROVE IT OUT OF THIS GREAT I
THINK THEY'RE GOING TO FACE SOM
HARSH REALITIES IN THIS FALLS
MIDTERMS, I THINK BIDEN WILL BE
THE 800-POUND GORILLA WITH
CEMENT BOOTS ON THE FEDERAL,
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL.
I THINK BECAUSE THEY ARE IN
DENIAL, I THINK THAT THE
DEVASTATING ABSOLUTE
ANNIHILATION THEY WILL FACE IN
2020 TO WILL HAVE LONG-TERM
BENEFITS FOR MULTIPLE ELECTION
CYCLES 2024 IN BEYOND.
>> YOU SAW THAT SATURDAY NIGHT
LIVE SKIT WHERE THEY SAY YOU
NEED MORE COWBELL.
DON'T FEAR THE REAPER, NO MATTE
WHAT HE WANTS MORE COWBELL.
MY SUSPICION IS THE ANSWER TO
THIS WILL BE MORE COWBELL, IT
WILL BE THEM BEING THE SAVIOR
FROM WHITE SUPREMACY AND MORE
AND LET'S SEE IF THAT DELIVERS
ON THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUFFERING IN THIS ECONOMY.
MORE COWBELL.